amazon are still considering an expanse
spin-off
but
there are a few problems
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so if you are a regular sidetracker
you'll know that i do speak to a few
people that work in and around mgm and
amazon and they get to tell me a little
bit of tidbits of information now
previously they told me that amazon did
actually in cooperation with the
production company that owns the rights
to expanse considered doing a few
different projects
after series 6 ended they did consider
making a trilogy of movies that got as
far as doing some concept art and things
but they decided very quickly that there
was just too much they they couldn't
give it do it justice and there was just
no way that three movies would work they
also did consider just continuing with
season seven
but the ways the book series six ended
there's been a 30-year gap between book
six and seven it's just a natural place
to pause the series also there's a lot
going on amazon i'm going to discuss in
a minute which also made pausing the
series very sensible for them from an
executive point of view
i did also tell you though that there
are other
entities like hbo max that have made it
very clear to the production company
that owns the expanse that if amazon
don't take up the rights to continue
making this series that they would
if you do like the content by the way
guys please consider hitting the
subscribe button consider sharing the
video wherever the hell you like him
hitting that like don't hit the down
that doesn't help anybody
also
consider becoming a fully fled side
track and hit the join button all these
little things they really help me to
keep the channel going in and then those
few little pennies that basically means
the wife will let me keep doing it
because actually amazon only owned the
distribution rights they don't actually
own the expense itself if they don't
take up the option to buy future series
the production company would be within
their rights to create a tv show for
another streaming service but
what i'm hearing at the moment is that
that isn't currently going to happen and
amazon are still very interested in
creating more expanse material but they
will not be making series seven what
they want to do instead is create a
spin-off series something that would
fill the gap those three decades between
books six and seven they think there are
lots of story ideas that they could work
on i'm thinking like the laconia empire
and the proto-molecule and all these
things that maybe don't follow through
with the other series but we could look
at um there are things story arcs within
certain characters that could be fleshed
out and followed up on there are lots of
loose threads throughout series six that
actually they could grab hold of and
make something new out of
i should tell you though that what i'm
being told from my sources close to
amazon that this series will not be of
the size and scale of the original six
series they want to do something that is
far more focused it'll have a much
smaller cast it'll have a focused
storyline on a specific story arc that
this would be a standalone series that
is completely separate in many ways from
the actual overarching storylines of the
first six books and that wouldn't really
feed in a great deal to the last three
books
my source is telling me that the idea
really is to have a far more achievable
vision a smaller cast less big sets less
cgi etcetera that the budget will not be
any more than the expenses had
previously in fact it might actually be
a bit less now as we know tv and
everything else costs more every single
year and that isn't going to change to
create a tv show to look today like it
looked a couple years ago costs more
money it just does
so
to have a smaller budget really is going
to have to mean that the production
company is going to require to be very
clever in the way they produce this
series but the exciting thing is they
are still considering the expanse that
isn't something that really has just
been thrown to one side this is
something that they would like to
produce
and that they're going to produce
something that is
different to the original but still has
the taste of the expanse series that we
love the realism for example so what do
you think get into the comments is this
something you really would like to see
i should also say that i'm being told
that this is not going to be in the next
12 months it may not even be the next
two years
there are big problems going on at
amazon they are focused very much on the
restructure of mgm there is a problem
that they may have spent too much money
on lord of the rings and that is a big
concern for any new projects coming up
in the next 12 months
there is also concerns that the momentum
for subscriptions of streaming services
has slowed it's even decreased slightly
as people are feeling the crunch from
the cost of living crisis and
considering where they're spending their
money they're actually spending less on
subscription services so all of these
things mean that this isn't something
that might happen in the next 12 months
but it is something that is still being
seriously considered and well could
happen at any point
so what do you think get in the comments
do you think this is something that you
do want to see are you also willing to
wait for it as long as they produce
something that's worthwhile
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit the bell notification
it really helps us out also
if you have enjoyed the content of these
videos and enjoy the channel as a whole
please consider becoming a fully fledged
side tracker hit the join button as
always guys please stay safe i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you